on this episode I bring the bucket Leo
and Emilio
[Music]
yes
ask Gary B
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 1 36 of the ask gary vee
show I'm fired up on this it is like i
just said mug mug it is muggy as hell in
New York City I'm like sweating right
now disgusted by the weather but very
excited because today is extremely
special day that special day is the fact
that it is my father Sasha vaynerchuk's
birthday happy birthday dad I love you
very very much all of you that watched
the show know how much of a factor my
parents are in my life and and you know
the time I spent with my dad working
every weekend every holiday vacation
every summer and then the first decade
of my professional career are moments I
think about all the time are constantly
running in my brain in parallel to as I
navigate the world and I love you very
much dad happy birthday happy birthday
playa applying my former assistants
weave that Instagram photo of me and all
the assistants let's put that up let's
not forget that let's put that up apply
a happy birthday and and so we've got
that and then big shout out to Facebook
live because we're doing that right now
the Mayo holding it down current
assistant status and and that's about it
I think there's a football game tonight
I the level of hate that I have for both
these franchises I mean the disdain I
have from Pittsburgh and New England is
so over the top I'm not even gonna go
into it but there's one picture from the
way I was reacting to the Steeler fans
last year in New York Iraq oh stuff ah
you know by the way let's actually start
talking about this Stefan has taken over
core editing editing you know control
and so all the love you're giving to
d-roc now needs to shift to Stefan at
the same token all the razzing you gave
Dirac for forgetting the fireballs last
time that was
Stefan's major miss rookie mistake we'll
let it go this time the Mayo you might
be editing this show if sivanna makes
another mistake so all right let's
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it let's get into the show
so you've been asking for it stun will
be very happy that we've actually used
the the reddit community to get feedback
in the bucket which I don't the rock
you're the only one who has a prayer
here do you know what episode the bucket
was on no Stefan all right well the
bucket made an appearance once people
liked it we're bringing it back so
random questions from the bucket
Andy K is here I feel like you're like I
feel like you're Leonardo DiCaprio and
growing pains like a random like new
person out of nowhere I was a tremendous
compliment alright Andy here we go let's
read them up I go to be why would you
spend money on a Facebook dark posts on
me when I follow you and I have
notifications this is tremendous because
you read this this is like so
serendipitous if you guys don't know
Andy does a ton of the paid performance
around my Brandon Wine Library and so
Andy I think you actually can answer
this question better than I can
what we're targeting is we're targeting
my fans on certain content retargeting
them because organically you're not
reaching everybody when you post
something and there's certain things
that I want everybody to see and Andy am
i right or wrong or do we even know yet
with the new notification with the way
the notifications are on we there's no
way to exclude people that have put us
on first look or anything yet yeah yet
and that's it so the answer to the
question is quite simple the reason I'm
targeting you is because there are
certain pieces of content that I want to
make sure as many people as possible see
above and beyond my normal organic reach
which is pretty high you know we tend to
get sixty to a hundred thousand of the
320,000 that we have which is extremely
high but sometimes I want all 320,000 of
you on facebook to see something and so
I'm willing to waste those pennies
not to mention is it a waste sometimes
think about you know what the rocket
back you're gonna get here the other way
let's let's get focus for a second here
here's a little side question a
statement of the day let's go into a
statement of the day number one here in
the comments section on YouTube and
Facebook please step up lurkers you're
pissing me off summer's over vacation is
over lurkers get your
asses in the comments the show's free I
need comments from you it is my oxygen
as you could tell I'm not joking around
leave in the comments if you've watched
a piece of content more than once the
answers let me let me save you a lot of
time answers most of you have watched
tons of my content more than once and so
even if it's wasted a lot of times
somebody will watch a second time a
third time one of the great ego boosts I
get are the emails I get that say things
like wow I just watched this talk for
the 7 time and I picked up on new things
because as your career involves same
with mine as our careers evolved other
things that were said now mean more than
they did six months ago and so that's
why I do it
the business model behind the askgaryvee
show is pretty simple
it is completely a a broad awareness
game
I want more exposure exposure is
leverage especially when you've got
chops the more people that know that I'm
not just charisma hyperbole [ __ ]
hype and that I have depth is something
that is important for my brand statement
of the day in the comments leave if you
originally thought that I was just
another [ __ ] marketer and have I won
you over with you doing the homework
about me actually building real
businesses multiple time and have
listened to things that I've talked
about here that you wouldn't expect from
a [ __ ] marketer and so anything that
puts me in a position to show my depth
in a world where I know that my
personality creates a scenario where
people may not think that I have that
depth is an important process for me
once I have the infrastructure to be
able to do it I did it and so the
business model is quite simple it's
about more leverage around me which
leads to in the short term things like
getting paid more for public speaking
selling more books getting asked to do
TV and other things and getting on 40
under 40 list which creates more
exposure and it's a rabbit wheel it
leads to better employees coming into
vaynermedia it leads to more people
buying on wine deals the greatest place
on Instagram to buy wine it leads to a
lot of other things it leads to depth
with
current employees because they get to
see so much more about me as a metric
here's a statement they've vaynermedia
lurkers because I know there's a lot of
you some of you been writing some
awesome feedback notes that are
completely taken from the askgaryvee
show vaynermedia employee lurkers
getting the comments on this episode and
say hey so it's given me the ability to
scale my thoughts and strategies to my
own employees
there's my mom gets to see me every day
she watched yesterday's episode twice
because AJ was in it she said
two-for-one for my mom I love you
there's an enormous enormous amounts of
ROI business models in the concept of
putting out great content putting out
great content if I may say so myself is
always the right idea the man out there
gonna like that one and I think you can
get some good comments in from Facebook
live dude do not do that do not do that
do not drive and watch the show
it's dangerous Gary tips to reach only
local residents on social we have a
recycling program that's specific to our
County I mean I wouldn't you weren't on
Andy they're open you caught them good
edit that because if you saw Andy's
reaction as the paid performance guy
that it's a looter ik ludicrous question
if it means that you know as I'm like
what I just said it Ludacris question
can you guys impose Ludacris in between
like next to me I baby it's a ludicrous
question if you've been watching the
show who asked that question is Liz if
you've been watching the show for the
last what so ever 130 episodes then that
I think you're just mailing in your
question but a glad you got on the show
because it's fun to be on the show but
Liz it's so simple
they spoke targetting I mean like I mean
that's it like you can literally put
your business address and run a mail
like a radius around it or everybody in
the oh seven oh eight one zip code or
208 802 as per a Jersey in the house
zip code and everybody will see it in
that in that zip code in that feed it's
a piece of cake you can do localized ads
with Instagram now you can do localized
ads with Twitter you know it's it's it's
the only place you can do this kind of
stuff outside of direct mail which is
very very expensive for the ROI of the
attention because everybody throws them
direct mail in the trash like this
question all right next Rex I hope we
don't ask the same question okay
oh you knew that's not really you don't
mean the paper what are the different
comes in the way you deal with small
there's a ton of differences you know
when you're dealing with small or big
businesses senior or junior employees
big or small in all shapes and sizes
in business really dictate very
different strategies so small accounts a
lot of times don't have the same budgets
small accounts often have chips on their
shoulder and lack confidence I think one
of the great things we do for small
accounts is actually bring a little
bravado to them because I'm more
comfortable actually coming from small
to going big because that's what I do
right and so there's you need to be
scrappier you need to build self-esteem
more I think big needs the reverse a lot
of times we need to make sure they don't
waste their money because they've you
know the the sorrows of riches or what
is it the hell mean what does it call
that you know anyway all right thank you
being there for me Andy you know like
like the spoils of riches or whatever
it's called like they have so much money
sometimes they just mail in and waste
the ton of it I think a lot of times our
biggest brands need a huge level of
humility I so it's really the yin and
yang to each other right I think the
small accounts need that bravado and
self-esteem and like we can do this like
screw the big guy if we're smarter we
can beat them they're wasting money on
TV and other dumb [ __ ] big account stop
wasting money on dumb [ __ ] you're not as
big and as cool as you think you are
somebody small can come and catch you so
those tend to be the two different
religious pillars and they're very
important and having those strategies at
the top really really do matter
right some me today
great job India Gary do you think
people's attention is reaching a max ie
it's now a fight between social
platforms to grab the pieces I think I
understand a question I mean look we
only have so many hours in the day right
so I think the basis of the question is
very simply like how many hours of
attention are really up for play and and
you've got television you've got
sleeping you've got eating you've got
working you've got your phone that has
tons of content you have video games you
have you know going to the bar your
fantasy football you have all these
things pulling at your direction you
have your kids you have your book club
like there's only so many hours and so
the leisure hours or the consumption
hours have have absolutely stayed the
same while the amount of content vying
for that attention has exploded our
grandparents had three goddamn TV
channels and two newspapers and two
radio stations vying for our attention
like that's how you got big that's how
Walter Cronkite was the most famous
person in America now we have massive
fragmentation and so yeah I think the
attention has not the you know the
attention is stayed stable while the
things pulling at that attention have
grown exponentially especially over the
last 15 years and the Internet has I
mean if you think cable television or
video games of the Nintendo era or you
know or you know or Direct TV then later
compares at all to what the internet is
doing you know it's a it's a thousand to
one I mean the the web and the phone I
mean the phone has become I mean it's
unbelievable to me how absolutely
essential that phone is Xander dropped
my phone on Sunday and me and Matt were
scrambling on Monday that me and Matt
were scrambling because Tuesday I was
going to LA and like you know it's just
like and I didn't have my phone for 15
hours and I was freaking the hell out
it was unbelievable it's kind of chill
actually but that only works for me
because it was Monday Labor Day into
Tuesday and I was home with the family
if I was to not have my phone now the
only time we ever fixed my phone
otherwise is when I'm in the office
so like I'm here okay but like literally
I was walking around my laptop thank God
I had
like my update on my on my iOS so my
text messages were coming in as chat but
like otherwise I would have been like
whatever and so to answer your question
the the yeah I think it's a it's a war
it will be a continuous war and the size
the big things in our society to be
smaller and smaller because everybody's
going to go into their niches we're
gonna micro celebrity micro trends that
long tail is going to be really really
really really long real long super long
great episode tomorrow is one of the
most special episodes in the history of
the askgaryvee show I will actually say
on record right now it will absolutely
be my favorite all-time ask Gary Vee
episode 100 throw up the 100 emojis and
don't forget Stefan you keep asking
questions because say minutes they yep
you know we've done them you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
[Music]